as you know we're all losing it a little
bit times are tough
so many things are screwed up at the
moment here in california we're dealing
with
fires yeah terrible fires i mean it's
much worse in northern california but
still i gotta tell you the air quality
is pretty bad here in los angeles too
now a lot of friends of mine that live
in other parts of the country have been
asking me
how bad is the air quality in la at the
moment
and i thought why not show you
yeah why don't i demonstrate how bad the
air is
it's a lot a lot more convincing than
just telling you so here's what i'm
gonna do
i've got a clean bleached white towel
right here i'm gonna hold it outside
in the la air and shake it around
for just a second and show you
that's how bad it is wow that is really
something
yeah that was quite a demonstration of
our air quality here in l.a
informative just not really very funny
well that's okay i mean we can always
just cut to a video of old people
working out to generic heavy metal
good idea andy
[Music]
you